because now they're disclosing private
information they start to build this
bond this trust and now they start to
look at each other with different eyes
yeah and so we just it can happen very
gradually but you know the bond that
they share can be super strong a lot of
times especially pre-pandemic when
everybody was working in the offices you
could see you could really spend more
quality time with your work spouse than
your real spouse you know if you get
home at six six thirty then you got the
kids and you got dinner and then get the
kids ready you know you might not spend
any quality time with your spouse until
8 39 9 o'clock and then you're in bed
trying to wake up early the next morning
whereas you spent all that time uh
Monday through Friday in the office
going to lunch outside of the office
sometimes going to dinner going for
drinks happy hour so you're spending
more quality time with your work spouse
than your real spouse so